Trascrizione: Ale Unam
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Sapete qual è il principale problema,
per l'imprenditore italiano?
Fallire.
E sapete qual è il principale vanto,
per un imprenditore americano?
Fallire, avere fallito,
ed essersi rialzati dopo il fallimento.
Perché questa differenza
tra l'America e l'Italia?
Perché in Italia il fallimento
è visto come un marchio di infamia,
un evento indelebile,
un ostacolo insormontabile?
E fa restare il fallito
dentro i propri limiti,
dentro i propri confini;
mentre negli Stati Uniti è visto
come un evento per rinascere,
e quindi per superare i propri limiti
e per diventare,
parafrasando il tema di oggi,
potremmo dire "unlimited".
La risposta in realtà c'è,
ed è nella Storia;
ma prima di rispondere
alle domande che vi ho posto,
vorrei raccontarvi due storie.
La prima è la storia
di un giovane imprenditore americano
che non ancora ventenne
fonda la prima azienda,
la propria azienda,
che commercializzava computer,
non ha successo e l'azienda fallisce;
ma non si dà per vinto,
fonda una seconda azienda
col suo miglior amico
che creava computer con processore Intel;
e anche questa impresa fallisce.
Non si dà ancora per vinto,
e passa dall'hardware al software,
e finalmente ha successo.
Sapete di chi sto parlando?
Di Bill Gates, l'uomo più ricco del mondo,
in fasi alterne con Jeff Bezos,
e creatore della Microsoft.
Non male, per un fallito.
La seconda storia, un po' più triste,
è la storia di un imprenditore italiano
non famoso come Bill Gates,
un imprenditore che ho conosciuto
per motivi professionali
il quale negli anni Ottanta
fonda la propria impresa,
con sei milioni di lire.
L'impresa cresce, diventa un'impresa
di successo con 1200 dipendenti,
più di 350 milioni di euro di fatturato;
questo imprenditore
è osannato dalla gente,
diventa un personaggio pubblico,
ha molti amici, molto seguito,
molti adulatori.
Purtroppo arriva la crisi del 2008,
il suo gruppo si trova avviluppato
in una spirale di crisi,
per uscirne fa degli errori
e un giorno, tornando da Dubai,
all'aeroporto di Malpensa viene arrestato
e portato in carcere a San Vittore,
nel famigerato sesto raggio.
Divide la cella di qualche metro quadro
con due delinquenti comuni
e due spacciatori.
Ci resta tre mesi,
e quando esce, nel frattempo,
la sua azienda è fallita.
Gli amici gli voltano le spalle,
si separa, perde tutto.
E si sente un fallito,
e viene considerato un fallito, un reietto
da quelli che prima lo osannavano.
La sua storia però non finisce qui;
la fine ve la racconto dopo.
Prima, cerco di rispondere alle domande
che vi ho posto all'inizio.
Perché in Italia c'è questa concezione
negativa del fallimento?
Come vi accennavo prima,
in realtà le origini
sono nella Storia e nel Medioevo,
dove il fallimento
è un istituto creato dai mercanti
per tutelare la buona fede negli affari.
Chi non paga i propri debiti
tradisce la fiducia dei propri creditori,
e quindi veniva imprigionato,
veniva bandito dalla società civile;
veniva posto molto spesso
in braghe di tela,
cioè un paio di mutandoni leggeri
ed esposto al pubblico ludibrio.
E, per esempio qui siamo a Mestre,
vicino c'è Venezia;
a Venezia andava in voga
la figura della pittima.
La pittima era un signore vestito di rosso
che inseguiva il debitore e gli diceva
"Ricordati che devi pagare,
ricordati che devi pagare",
tutto il giorno:
abbastanza estenuante, direi.
Però credo che anche a noi, ogni tanto,
farebbe comodo avere una pittima
per inseguire i nostri debitori;
ma non è possibile.
Questa concezione negativa del fallimento
si è perpetuata nei secoli,
fino a giungere ai giorni nostri.
E laddove il fallimento di una persona
spesso si confonde
con il fallimento dell'oggetto;
cioè il fallimento dell'azienda
si confonde con il fallimento
dell'imprenditore,
quindi spesso non fallisce l'imprenditore
ma fallisce l'azienda.
E si dice di quell'imprenditore
che è un fallito,
e l'imprenditore viene espunto dal mondo
non solo dell'economia,
ma anche dalla società civile,
nel senso che viene
considerato un reietto.
E perché è così diversa -
quasi come se fosse un virus,
quasi un CoVid19 -
Perché in America è così diversa
la concezione del fallimento?
In America - in realtà,
l'America è un paese
che si fonda su un principio:
il principio del fresh start,
del nuovo inizio.
L' America è un Paese
fondato da immigrati:
immigrati i primi
padri pellegrini della Mayflower
che fuggivano dalle persecuzioni
religiose in Europa;
gli irlandesi che fuggivano
dalle carestie;
gli italiani che fuggivano dalla povertà;
gli ebrei che fuggivano dal nazismo.
Ecco, tutti fuggivano da qualcosa
che avevano, se volete, "fallito"
nella loro vita precedente:
e cercavano una nuova vita,
un "fresh start" appunto.
Tanto che, ancora oggi,
gli imprenditori di successo americani
quando narrano le loro storie di successo
partono dei loro fallimenti,
ostentano i loro fallimenti;
a differenza di un imprenditore italiano,
che nasconde se ha avuto
dei fallimenti nella sua vita.
Ma tutti abbiamo avuto dei fallimenti;
alzi la mano chi di voi,
una volta, non ha mai fallito,
almeno una volta nella vita.
Non solo nella parte professionale,
ma anche nella parte personale.
D'altronde, fallire deriva da fallere,
che vuol dire cadere, inciampare.
E capita a tutti di cadere, o inciampare,
almeno una volta nella vita.
Ecco: in America,
il concetto di fresh start
si accompagna a un altro concetto
molto interessante,
che è il concetto di
"fail fast, learn fast":
fallisci velocemente
per imparare velocemente.
È più importante un insuccesso elaborato
che un successo rapido e superficiale.
Tanto che nella Silicon Valley,
che è il centro dell'innovazione,
tenete presente che il tasso di insuccesso
di un'azienda è del 90%.
Solo che lì, memore di questi principi,
i giovani startupper,
dopo i loro fallimenti,
si rialzano e ripartono,
più entusiasti di prima,
più forti di prima,
coscienti dei propri errori.
Quindi, qual è il messaggio
che vi voglio lasciare oggi
da questo talk,
che vi vorrei lasciare oggi?
Il messaggio in realtà è "Never give in".
Lo disse Churchill molti anni fa,
il famoso discorso "Non mollare mai".
Perché noi siamo abituati
a concepire il fallimento
come una porta che si chiude;
e se fosse una finestra che si apre?
Il fallimento non è, o meglio non è solo,
la fine di un qualcosa.
Il fallimento è l'inizio di qualcos'altro,
se lo vogliamo ovviamente
e se ci rimbocchiamo le maniche.
È l'inizio di una nuova avventura,
di una nuova ricerca anche di noi stessi.
Di fronte a una caduta,
di fronte al fallimento,
abbiamo due opportunità:
la prima è rimanere per terra,
e lamentarci dei nostri problemi,
della nostra sfortuna, del fato avverso.
La seconda possibilità è di rialzarsi,
più forti e determinati di prima,
consapevoli dei propri errori,
e combattere.
Ecco: probabilmente consapevole
di questo insegnamento,
o forse anche inconsapevole
e forse anche inconsciamente,
adesso vi racconto la fine
della storia dell'imprenditore
di cui vi accennavo prima,
l'imprenditore che è stato in prigione
che ha avuto delle disavventure.
In realtà, questo imprenditore
ha fondato una nuova azienda,
si è rimboccato le maniche,
non si è dato per vinto.
Ha fondato un'azienda attiva
nel settore del commercio,
di import di prodotti dalla Cina,
di prodotti sanitari;
e l'anno scorso, nel pieno
della crisi mondiale,
ha sfruttato questa crisi
e la sua azienda, la sua nuova azienda,
ha avuto un boom di fatturato
con un utile post tasse, pagate le tasse,
di due milioni di euro.
Non male per un fallito, direi.
E quindi, vi lascio con questo
potremmo dire, suggerimento,
a voi e a me stesso:
a tutti capita di cadere.
E quindi, quando cadiamo
ringraziamo di essere caduti,
e rialziamoci facendo tesoro
dei nostri errori,
più forti e determinati di prima.
Never give in, grazie.
(Applausi)